you guys are reminding me of like so
many of my like university projects and
dissertations
like i remember i remember my
dissertation was like
did your dissertations feel like a
[ __ ] lifetime to complete yeah
it was mine because mine did i remember
um like what the station had several
stages and
i remember like depression like one of
the first stages we had
i had to like build like a wireless
wireless uh wireless antenna so we had
to like
had to build a system where i could like
transfer
data wirelessly and my friend actually
helped me help me build it
and i remember we basically just we
basically just recreated probably the
invention of porn
right okay because what happened right
we were working on we were working on
this
for like an entire day and we couldn't
we couldn't get it working we were like
why why is data not transmitting is the
receiver may be receiving the signals
wrong we don't know and then
suddenly after so much work we like we
like get it working we get we
we send like this message like hello
world or something yeah some basic ass
message and it was just like
the [ __ ] eureka moment it was such it
was like such a bro moment i was like
yes we got this message to send we got
data
from one antenna to another wirelessly
and then we just looked at each other
we're like so what do we do now and he
just goes
let's try sending ascii porn
it's not even real no no we couldn't
send that much later at that time so we
were just like
what can we send let's send ascii
boobies so so we
google we google like a naked girl with
like
through an ascii filter yeah and then we
try sending that and we're like
yeah it [ __ ] works so it's always
like
and thus porn wait this is exactly how
porn was started
just just imagine just imagining some
scientists having this eureka moment
like getting like imagine like the
telegram being invented
and the next thing they want to send is
[ __ ] ascii porn or something like
that i don't remember that in history
like exactly we could go to the store to
buy the playboy magazine
or you could just send it to me while
i'm home
i was like jacking off to ascii exactly
okay but like i remember
it i remember going all the way forward
to when i had to present it and i'm like
i'm still [ __ ] pissed to this day
because i had my project which i worked
so [ __ ] hard on right
um and i actually i actually knew it was
it was actually working
it was it was like it was like like wow
wow i had it was many sleepless nights
many red bulls to get this [ __ ]
tracking system working that i had been
working on all year
and so for some reason for some reason
you know you know like that [ __ ]
professor yeah that just seems to wake
up
and he just has like he just wants to be
an [ __ ] yeah
he just for some reason that was the day
he woke up and he wanted to be an
[ __ ] right
so he just starts grilling me on this
presentation on my presentation
um and asking me questions that you know
that you shouldn't expect from my level
basically right i mean i was doing a
master's but he was asking me like phd
level questions right i don't know why
and we i was i was there
for a good like 20 minutes why do you
hate me because
because i swear the questioning was
meant to be like 10 minutes max he's
going to ask you 10 minutes worth of
questions
it goes on for 20 minutes oh my god and
i'm like sweating it was like the worst
job interview i've ever been in
like you know when you just you know
when you're just spitting [ __ ] and
you don't even know if it's correct
anymore yeah that was
that was like that was like the point i
was getting at so so he finishes with me
and i'm just like
oh what the [ __ ] why did he do that to
me i'm like sweating
i didn't even get a good mark for my
presentation
but what really kills me is that the
person next to me
was the one girl in my class the one
girl
in an engineering class oh i didn't
grill her and
okay so i saw his face so he like when
he was like grinding me he was like
he was like eyebrows firewood like yeah
whatever i i don't give a [ __ ] about
what you said
goes up to the next person hi what's uh
what project do you have here the boy's
horny on me
oh that's that's sweet and i know i know
for a fact that she didn't know
that thing didn't [ __ ] work she she
didn't put any [ __ ] work into it
but she got a higher mark on the
presentation than me
and my thing actually worked and some
[ __ ] you it's like well now we know who
is sucking the professor off
after class